il s'appelle la fille du
dragon
elle veut le faire pour moi nous avons
encore une idée
je ne sais pas d'où tu viens tu es la
bienvenue à tout moment
quand on me baise Colleen elle
essaie juste de survivre commençons
Colleen à travailler le  dojo cette année ouais
elle regarde les enfants ces exercices
consistent à essayer de vous apprendre à
performer dans le monde réel elle représente la
discipline d'honneur l'autodiscipline mais elle
a cet avantage que diriez-vous d'avoir un autre
combattant quand je vous gagne le double de mon salaire
vous êtes  une nana folle, tu sais que
Colleen n'a pas beaucoup de problèmes financiers,
elle est dans une situation si difficile qu'elle finit par
aller dans un club de combat que tu cours pour
la partie de ta paroisse qui finit par aimer ça
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est jamais une femme mince  est forte et
ses affaires Colleen je veux le
défier après qu'il doit la gagner je
vous demande gentiment d'être une réaction initiale rapide
est vous êtes fou mais ensuite quand
elle voit à quel point elle est bonne elle
commence à réaliser  c'est autre chose
à propos de lui
[Musique]
assez dangereux
il y a Andrew elle est curieuse il est tellement
intrigant et il est si différent de tous ceux
qu'elle a rencontrés elle va te tuer
ça n'arrivera pas alors elle prend un
pari nous pouvons faire beaucoup de bien ensemble
tu es la seule personne  qui peut m'aider
c'est une relation très dramatique
mr.  e une si grande partie de notre émission et
il y a un élément d'où cet état
était-il censé être Je pense qu'elle sait que
c'est Danny plus long et plus de la moitié mais
c'est enivrant je vais avec toi
oh tu n'es rien
je veux dire c'est incroyable  les gens qui aiment le travail
super chaussures féminines fer poing est
dans une catégorie à part
c'est un spectacle qui vous prend sur vos orteils
vous
[applaudissements]
combats ivres
j'allais dire apportez-le regardez vous les
gars connaissez toutes les règles hein
tapez sur  sur les KO du mauvais chemin hors de
cette cage sinon tout ce qui marche
tu es sûr que tu veux
[Applaudissements]
petite fille allons-y
[Musique]
bébé